Vanessa Bryant says life truly isn't
fair as she pays tribute to her late
husband Kobe Bryant on Mamba day four
years ago on April 13 2016 Kobe played
his final NBA game the game was against
the Utah Jazz at the Staples Center
where Kobe scored 60 points leading the
Lakers to victory that night ever since
then April 13th has been deemed Mamba
day for his fans referencing his famous
nickname to my family my wife Vanessa
I'll do it as Natalia Gianna you know
thank you guys for all your sacrifice
you know for all hours I've spent in the
gym working and training
Vanessa you hold them down the family
the way that you have I can't there's no
way that I could thank you enough for
that so from the bottom of my heart
thank you and
what can I say mom our on Monday Vanessa
took to Instagram with a heartfelt
message acknowledging her husband's 20
years of hard work and the pain she
feels now that he is no longer here
she writes quote all he wanted was to
spend time with our girls and me to make
up for lost time he wanted to be there
for every single milestone and special
moment in our girls lives he only got to
enjoy three years and nine months of
retirement she goes on to say we had two
more daughters he won an Oscar he opened
Granite E Studios he became a five-time
best-selling author and coach Gianna's
basketball team in that time y'all
practice every night is that every
single night what what is that like
every night practice well I'll make it
fun right so you make it things that
they're learning mm-hmm you make it
enjoyable you don't run them you know
you know all this crazy stuff but you
just teaching the game in increments
right you got a five-year plan just
teach the game patiently and see where
they are five years from now the mother
of four also acknowledged her late
daughter Gianna Bryant's work ethic that
matched Kobe's saying quote she worked
hard and gave her all seven days a week
just like her daddy I wish I could go
back to that morning every day I wish
they had a normal local game on January
26th life truly isn't fair this is just
senseless despite the unimaginable pain
vanessa has managed to stay strong for
her three daughters
seventeen-year-old Natalia three year
old Bianca and nine month old Capri on
Sunday the wife of the late NBA star
shared beautiful photos of her and her
daughters celebrating their first Easter
without Kobe and Gigi she even posted
this adorable video of Bianca and Capri
enjoying some Easter treats
[Music]
[Music]
back in February a source close to the
family told ET that Vanessa knows the
grieving process will be long and hard
the source went on to say that Vanessa
found Kobe's memorial to be healing she
is overwhelmed with the outpouring of
love her and her family received it was
the perfect tribute to Kobe and Gigi
[Music]